the elephant totally avoided the mouse
he looked down saw it backed up made a
wide berth around this little guy I met
this little girl she was maybe seven
eight years old and like a lot of
children she was super freaked out to
see me in front of her in person and she
kind of like and then almost immediately
she stopped and went I wanted to ask
about the elephants are afraid of mice
myth I'm wondering why you used white
mice because albino mice are very common
in nature why would you use that if
that's not something that's common in
nature and her science brain had totally
overloaded her her brain that was
self-conscious about meeting me we
shouldn't have used an albino mouse
she's a hundred percent correct and I
loved telling her that she was right cuz
she was thrilled
if you'd asked me 14 years ago and told
me Mythbusters was going to be a huge
success that's going to run for a decade
and a half what would you like legacy to
be I would have said oh wow I really
hope the legacy that we show that
science is deeply creative and introduce
people to real critical thinking and
that seems to be what we've done